Vines, branches, and tendrils grab at
682’s wriggling body, as the skinless,
grinning face of the Skeleton Queen bears
down. She is in total control. For one of
the first times ever, 682 has encountered a
threat who might be too powerful for even its
strength and adaptability to surpass. How could
such an impossible circumstance come to pass?
Lost in an endless abyss of liminal realities,
separated from its closest companions,
and officially declared to be neutralized
by The SCP Foundation, the immortal
reptilian entity known as 682 continues its
incomprehensible journey through The Backrooms.
682 had explored over twenty different levels of
the Backrooms, from vast oceans, to lost cities,
to even mind-warping spaces that evoked distant
childhood memories. Very little, if any,
of what 682 had encountered could be described as
fun or adventurous. In 682’s mind, The Backrooms
was a nightmare controlled by malicious forces
that only wanted to bring harm to the creature.
The lizard had faced scores of violent entities
ranging from low-level fodder like clumps,
smilers, and death moths, spear-wielding
mini-bosses like Tiny and Argus, and one
particularly crafty and well-equipped elderly
explorer. Through all of these encounters and
the dimension-hopping hijinks that came with
them, 682 had become enduring and resilient.
The uncontrollable rage and disgust for life that
had defined 682’s personality during its time in
containment had gradually subsided into an almost
enlightened state of determination. The will to be
its own master, decide its own destiny, and
to travel The Backrooms not as a conqueror,
but as an entity seeking freedom for its sake.
It spent a long time contemplating its purpose
in the cryptic ruins of the petrified garden on
level 23 before making a new effort to travel
between layers of the backrooms. As one might
expect, the next level that 682 was able to
access was Level 24, known by some as The Study,
but better known by its locals as The Moon.
Even as far as levels in the Backrooms go,
level 24 was an unusual concept for 682 to
understand at first. The walkable portion of the
level appeared to be a plastic model of a moon,
blown up to colossal proportions. The moon
was part of a scale model of the solar system,
and was situated inside a Victorian-era
study of impossible size. The exact details
of the massive room were hard to see,
given the anomalous blurry filter that
appeared to impede the vision of those
who tried to look away from the moon.
“Hmm… no consistent theme with the previous
levels, vague and inexplicable properties,
and a seemingly random resemblance to human-made
structures. Classic backrooms,” 682 mused.
In the distant expanse of the study, Entity
682 thought that it saw a titanic human man
in a tuxedo pulling a book from one of the shelves
and sitting down to read it. This blurry giant was
known simply as “Beuford” and he was the only
unique entity to this level of the Backrooms.
The craters and rifts of the moon were
home to swarms of death moths and clumps,
though there were noticeably not as many
of these hostile entities as on prior
levels. 682 regarded the presence of these
familiar foes as something of a novelty,
given the amount of time it had spent
on the relatively safe level 23.
The more things change, the more
they stay just as disgusting.
While 682 was not exactly pleased with having to
share the same reality as these infernal things,
it was not about to rush in
and start taking names. If
the researchers at the Foundation could
see SCP-682 now, they might assume that
the reptile had been reformed of its
violent ways. This was not the case.
682 had come to accept that these creatures had no
real ecosystem or drive to propagate themselves as
other life did. The mechanics of their existence
seemed to be limited to the mere fact that they
were extensions of the Backrooms itself: obstacles
placed in the path of explorers to thwart their
progress. They were more like the enemies of
a video game than sentient lifeforms, and 682
had come to believe that fighting them would be
doing exactly what the Backrooms wanted it to do.
If 682 needed to defend itself, it would
absolutely fight back against these stock
entities, but by now, it was obvious that they
were not a real threat. There were better games
to play in the arcade of life, and 682 was
not feeling particularly flush with tokens.
Appropriately enough, the next level that
682 arrived at - level 25 - was filled with
a wide selection of arcade machines.
Once again, the Backrooms had thrown
another devious curve ball in the direction of
682. The hard to destroy reptile was reminded
once again of just how unpredictable the
variations in theme could be between levels.
True to its retro aesthetic, Level 25 seemed to
be covered in a thin layer of dust. The arcade
machines themselves were damaged and broken
down. The few that did seem functional were not
equipped with any game that 682 was familiar with.
Then again, 682 was not exactly an avid gamer.
Perhaps the sorry state of the arcade would
be explained by the level being where the 80s
went to die or, more likely, by the fact no human
explorer had made it this far into the Backrooms
in quite some time. The lack of humans in an
environment designed for them was hardly a new
occurrence inside of the Backrooms, and as usual,
the general idea seemed to be that something that
was usually normal, like a hotel or an office,
presented in a way that made it inconvenient.
An arcade where no games could be played was
certainly a bummer, but considering that it
several layers farther down than a level where
explorers were forced to confront their traumatic
pasts, and another level that threatened all
explorers with evershifting extreme environments,
the plight of being stuck in a defunct
arcade was a bit of an underwhelming concept.
682 had long since accepted that there was no
linear difficulty curve to the Backrooms, and
given that this place was also devoid of entities,
Level 25 didn’t seem to have much to offer the
reptile. With no other options, 682 decided to try
one of the arcade machines. Naturally, it didn’t
carry any quarters on its being, but that was only
a minor quibble to a creature as adaptable as 682.
I can do anything.
As 682 approached one of the functional arcade
machines, it developed a quarter-shaped skin
tag on the tip of its snout, similar to the
knobby growth of a male gharial crocodile.
It extended this growth towards the coin
slot on a wire-thin appendage. As if it
were an actual quarter, 682 did its best
impression of placing a quarter inside of
an arcade machine. Once the machine blinked
to life, 682 retracted its organic quarter.
The bright screen of the cabinet began
to shuffle rapidly through numbers like
a slot machine. It did this for several minutes
until landing on the number 28. Sparks of energy
coursed through the arcade cabinet, and a sudden
burst of light whisked 682 several levels ahead.
682 could see a tunnel of light on all sides
as it flew through the liminal space between
liminal spaces. It was able to perceive a hint
of level 26 - a seemingly ordinary apartment
building - and level 27 - an innocent looking
hot spring inside of a cave. Both concepts
were old hat at this point, so 682 didn’t
feel too bad about skipping them. Besides,
it was a free being now, and what was freer than
breaking the rules and skipping a few levels?
Unless the Backrooms were hoping it would do that?
But there was no time to think about the
inscrutable intentions of the abyss’ creators,
because 682 had reached the other side of the
light tunnel and been deposited into level 28 - a
dimension with a navy blue sky and a single
large castle on the hill - the only landmark.
682 moved towards the castle and was greeted by
the sound of a great thunder above. Dark storm
clouds began to fill the sky as rain poured
down onto the forested valley surrounding the
keep. While no ordinary storm would deter a
being as powerful as 682, the howling winds
and flashes of lightning signaled that
this weather was anything but ordinary.
The reptile naturally decided to continue
into the only available shelter - the castle.
It barged in through one of the walls
in an effort to hide itself from the
elements. It soon learned that it
was not alone. A foreboding figure
approached from the darkness of the keep,
clad head to toe in colorful blue armor.
“Who goes there? Answer me, you scaly knave!”
Feeling a bit spicy, 682 decided to
break out an old favorite threat:
“What good does it do for a lamb to
know the name of its butcher? I am
simply passing through. You’re just one more
lifeless husk dreamed up by the Backrooms,
so leave me be and return to your
dull routine of scaring weak humans.”
“Foul beast!” The Blue Knight said. “I
would never scare humans on purpose. I
happen to quite respect them. As a matter of fact,
I have met a particularly good human
who taught me so many wonderful things.”
“You say you’ve met a good human?” 682
asked. “Other than the exception of the dead,
I can’t think of any humans that are
worthy of existence, let alone ‘good.’”
“Well then, you don’t know
Sarah!” The Blue Knight said,
seemingly in a state of rising emotional distress.
The storm outside began to grow in intensity
in response to the Blue Knight’s provoked
reaction. 682 found this somewhat intriguing and
decided to push the armored figure a bit further.
“Is she your girlfriend?” 682 taunted.
682 was becoming simultaneously more amused and
disgusted by this Blue Knight as the interaction
went on. It was clear that the Blue Knight was
a bit of a lunatic and definitely a soft-hearted
being, though as 682 pondered his words, an odd
feeling of realization washed over the reptile.
Was the current situation regarding 682’s lost
traveling companion - Entity 7 Jerry - not
dissimilar from what the knight was going
through in regards to this human named Sarah?
682 had learned much about the Backrooms during
his time traveling with the blue hyacinth macaw
and did miss the avian entity very much. The
idea that Jerry may have forgotten about 682
and might be on adventures somewhere
else made 682 almost feel regretful.
Suddenly, tormenting this overly sensitive knight
didn’t seem to be that much fun to 682. All at
once, the reptile wanted out of this level,
so he ordered the night to give him an exit.
The blue knight shook its head for a
bit, but ultimately relented. He led
682 to an archway deep in the castle made
of solid bones. It was a dimensional portal,
like many of those seen in the Backrooms,
and it was carved with the number 32.
“This portal shall take you to the Forest
of the Skeleton Queen on level 32. It is
a dangerous place where you will almost
certainly meet your demise. The Skeleton
Queen is not known for her hospitality.”
The Forest of the Skeleton Queen was about
what one might expect from its name. A dark
and gloomy woodland beneath a starless sky
and a crescent moon. Of course, there were also
the countless skeletons floating among the trees
to give the level some personality.
All of them seemed somewhat alive,
but like many of the Backrooms other
tricks, this may have only been an illusion.
It’ll do.
Before 682 could even fully take in the scenery,
it could see another entity moving between the
trees. It appeared to be a human woman in a
Victorian dress and skeletal face paint. She
appeared to gesture to 682, beckoning the
reptile into the forest. There was nothing
to lose yet, so 682 took the mysterious
woman’s provocation and followed her.
Not too far down the path, 682 lost sight
of this strange human woman. It was as if
she had been there a moment and was gone
the next. 682 pondered the odd nature of
this encounter and decided to turn back
around and follow a different path.
As soon as 682 turned, the woman appeared
before the reptile again, but this time her
overall form was a lot more sinister. She
was tall and gaunt, with hardly any skin,
and the white of her bones shone ominously in the
moonlight. She smiled an evil smile, and without a
single word, she snapped her fingers - causing
the entire forest to immediately turn on 682.
It was an attack more sudden and more complete
than any 682 had ever experienced. There was
no chance to sense her hostility, no
room to adapt or to react. The trees
took hold of 682 and in a display of immense
supernatural power that defied all logic,
tore 682’s very spirit out of its physical form
and dragged into the darkness beneath the forest.
In its long and miserable life, the immortal
reptile 682 had endured every punishment
and form of damage in creation, but here and
now in the Backrooms, for the very first time,
682 would not have the luxury of its hard
to destroy infinitely adaptable body. It was
now a helpless, disembodied soul without any
means to defend itself, the perfect plaything
for the Skeleton Queen herself. Has the
unkillable reptile truly been killed?
Now check out “Could SCP-682 be Contained in the
Backrooms?” and “SCP-682 Makes
Friends in BACKROOMS” for more!